いやー
もう3年前かこんにちははじめ社長ですこの記述はですね結構あのいろんな地域で成人
式が行われていると思います僕の頭でもですね今年で成人中で今多分性重視気に入って
いるころでしょう
おめでといやあもうね懐かしいんですよね僕が帝人式だったらもう3年前なのでもう
あれから3年ぷしましたトレーダーの成人された皆様おめでとうございます
僕みたいな大人にならないようにしようねちょっとで僕にとって成人式はねかなり
デカイ物だったんでちょっとね今日は老化が政治意識三渕と話そうと思います面白いか
わかんないけど外もいろいろね政治資金とかで僕の中学時代につつ話そうと思います
まずですねっと成人式っていうので結構地域で行われます
まずで生成しきっていうのは結構地域でこんなはね
あまり高校のメンバーが集まるというよりかは中学とかですね小学校とか中学校の椎木
地元で集まったメンバーという自意識で会うことが多いんですよなんで僕の成人式も
その地域で集まったので小学校中学校の友達がたくさんいました
ズバに今子なんですけども基本的に女の人が苦手なんですよだいぶマシにはなったと
思うんですけども基本的にちょっと苦手
なぜこんなことになったかっていうのもちゃんと今回はわかりやすく説明してあげ
ましょう
というわけで僕の成人式のエピソードですどうぞいっぱいと言うけど俺の成人式で
ございますそれ自身といえばねスーツを着たり袴とか来たり女の子は猫の中着物とか着
てみんなおめかしして
うわぁ成人まあみたいなちょっと楽しい感じなんですけども僕はスーツで行きましたが
ここでちょっと話が降ったかかるんですけど僕は中学校の時に女友だちが
ほぼいませんまず右手大きな鍵となったのは中学2年生の秋ロー結構増えて中学校の
ときは副生徒会長をやってたって
学校の中でもちょっとこう頑張ってちょっと目立ってる系の男子だったんです中学生活
をいい感じに送っていたんですけども学習発表会分科会みたいなのは中学校にあった秋
の時期なんですけどもうねそのなんかの分科会とかでこの
はじめの言葉とか言うんで結構目立ってたんではもうね一緒にけど結構目立ってたんで
やっぱりこれ
他者をないと思ったらモテちゃっててもでか結果ですねこう可愛い女の子からですね
学習発表会が終わった後に告白されましてはじめ口にみたいなで簿完備ビッターズで
阿蘇びっくりしたんですけどもうちょっと嬉しくてまぁ中学校でよくあるんですけど
一期良いで付き合っちゃったとこがあって
で付き合ったんですけども6月4日の時はみんなね携帯とかスマホとか持ってなくて
友達と連絡する時もうメール勝ち方でしたあそボンドね僕は家にあるお父さんの
パソコンで逆でアカウントを作ってログインして yahoo メールで毎日その子と
メールをしていたわけですよ何食べたんかつどん
ふーんばいばいもっとなんかもうちょっと詳しく話せと思いやでもねあんなに山第二期
とか二期とかね
言える感じなかったんですけどもこっそりお父様使ってない時間を狙ってこうねヤフー
メールでね話いったわけなんですよ
しかし僕は思ってやる忙しかったバスケ部でグリグリ部活をがっつりやってたからと8
外でですねなんか服が異常だったので順に仕事があったので朝が早かったりして大きい
基本的に学校で会うことはできないんですよ同じクラスだったんですけどもなんか女子
は交通て固まって打者だして固まってたし僕ととのコツなく鍵はもヤフーメールしか
なかったんですよゼマン接触不明のそれだけですけどもやっぱり忙しくで時間がなかっ
たことお父さんがパソコンを使ってたりしたのであんまりねメールをする時間が取れず
に付いたらレールをあんまりしないようになっていました経営度スマ
がないとに結構大変だったんですよ直接学校でね今日はメールできなくてごめんねとか
火を使う言葉も言えずに食べることなく男子が進んでいきました
なんでこんなことになってしまったんだろうなぜかそのことは口がきけなくなりメール
も打つ気にもなれずお互い学お互いちょっと先量になってなんか酒っていうの生活が
続いてしまって付き合ってるなら付き合ってないのかもよくわからず自然消滅
してしまいました女性にはね力のねちょっと3分のねこの制度があると思うんですよ
これが僕はどっちのカースト制度とよっております多分だっチェンジもねそういう感じ
なのがあったと思うんですけどもこちらね助手の監査制度の巣がありますぞー to
get ピラミッド型に分かれているんですけど萌えちゃんねる解きかわいい電気とか
ねこう流行に乗るお笑い
ダイステレビ大好きみたいな by my キャプチャ pk で男子カット制度の上
のグループと欧米の女神のグループが何か良いんで中会場に入ると雨少し可愛い子とか
普通のことがちょっと中堅クラスの音勉強も結構できるような子がカットまるちゅう会
人がありますそして彼そうなんですけどもここには一匹狼とかでをしていて行動したり
ちょっとカバー
あったことかねちょっと個性的な子とか仮想がありますが男性もそうだと思うんです
けどもなんか中学校高校はねこういう謎のピラミッドそんなか身分制度ができると思う
んですよ
僕の学校ではねここでですね僕の付き合った女の子のポジションの話をするんですけど
もはいこちらになります女子の完成度のピラミッドの上層部のてっぺんここで女子の
関数と制度のか
なミッドのてっぺんに君に住んでこんなことはチョ氏の金庫の学年の女子の中トップ
みたいな男児のとだったんですけども終わら
よーく考えてみてくれ女子のこのピラミッドの頂点に君臨するライオンキングとの自然
消滅は何を意味する滑走
すべての女子との自然消滅ですこれはこの後と別れてから
すべてのぞストー
口がきけだから女子は是非その後に服従してるわけないしたかってるわけでねトップの
女の子が気まずい
俺にでこのほかのならを話すことはもうでタブーなんですよもう違法違法行為だったね
同学年の女の子かの基本的に無視され話しかけられもせずまるで空気のような存在でし
た
僕の中学校時代はこの子とすでしょ右手してから中学校はその後基本的に
女の子と話すことはなかったです次の待ってですねちょっとねなんて苦手というかね
怖いんですよ女性がいつ話してくれたけどとわかんないからねちょっと苦い中学時代の
思い出があります男子は仲良くしてくれたんでな階段所にいるんですけどもカウント
程度増サーブの女子のな外部できない男子がそんななんかば祝いできるわけでもないの
で昔柄に中学校生
月を送ってますかいわゆる北の地域ではば勝つと苦い思い出があるんでね基本陰キャラ
よりだったんですけどもそういう感じで迎えました成人式の日でございますたまたまな
んですけどその母た制度のトップに与するジョシュと僕はですね
同じ地区に住んでおりまして成人式でも結構ね会う機会があったんで僕が頑張って
話しかけてみたんですよ
いや久しぶりみたいな感じで話を見た
んですけどなんか自然と話せました恋愛だねその場の勢いでですねなんか昔はす前消滅
した米派
チャーハンみたいな話もできて他にとかねあの時はごめんねみたいな話ができたという
話ですせいぜい鹿ですね僕がちょっと悔やんでたことを一つ解決できたという思いで
ございますまぁでも結局僕の中学校のポジションは基本員じゃなかったんで
フェスよね次回かな
と2で変えちゃったし
ます
みんなでも専従士や楽しいもんだからね
ぜひ楽しんで下さいじゃあ